an example of a modern wife we have in
the media is Kim Kardashian Kim
Kardashian is an example of a woman that
puts herself first and really she puts
herself first at the expense of her
family over the past couple years we
have seen the evolution of Kim and Kanye
and you saw Kanye really coming to God
and you saw him becoming more of a
Christian man over time now I know I'm
not saying he's the perfect example of a
Christian he's probably not I know he
went viral for you know this ual his
wife doing that to him in public but
okay sorry guys but we saw him married
to Kim and expressing his discomfort
with her dressing sexually in America
her argument was you found me like this
why should I change and again Kim you
are supposed to act differently when you
are a wife and a mother it is not all
about money it is not all about
attention